karim veut visiter le costa rica
elle a du temps devant elle elle ne sait
pas quand elle rentrera au pays
elle achète donc le billet aller simple
mais le jour du départ comptoir de la
compagnie aérienne
on lui annonce qu'il ya un problème
l'agente est clair si elle veut monter
dans l'avion
elle doit d'avoir un billet aller-retour
en main mais 12.7 règles de vente
catherine cette obligation ne vient pas
de la compagnie aérienne
bédié du pays où elle sera depuis 2011
le costa rica oblige tous les non
résidents avoir un billet aller retour
pour rentrer au pays
il n'y a pas que le costa rica des pays
comme cuba et la jamaïque ont la même
pratique finalement catherine voulais
tellement partir en voyage qu'elle s'est
résolu à acheter un billet de retour à
la sauvette le fin mot de l'histoire
partie ressemblant c'est bien connaître
d'abord les exigences des pays que l'on
visite et c'est mieux